now let's talk about or get
understanding on the types of
cloud computing we can categorize the
different types of cloud computing based
on two wide categories
one being a deployment model and the
other one being
service model let's talk about the
deployment model first
deployment model is categorized into
three types first one is public
and then private and then hybrid cloud
in other words public cloud private
cloud and hybrid cloud
it'll be easy for me to explain and also
it'll be easy for you to understand if i
walk you through this example
consider the different types of vehicles
we use to commute
from one place to another for example if
i want to travel
i can pick a bus which is accessible to
anyone i get in
and i pay for the seed that i occupy and
i pay for the time that i will be
traveling in it and i'm done cost is
very less here a similar kind of thing
happens in the public cloud i pay only
for the resource that i use
and i pay for how long i use it if i use
less i pay less if i use more i pay more
for that month simple on the other hand
private cloud is like
buying your own car and using it for
commuting purpose
here i pay a huge amount upfront and it
is all owned only by me
i do not pay for it in an hourly fashion
but completely
and all up front the cost here is very
huge
and thirdly if i want the best of both
types
like the comfort of the own car and
still don't want to pay all upfront
otherwise want only to pay for the time
that i use the service
i can rent a car similarly i can have it
in a hybrid environment meaning if i
already have a dc
i can integrate it with the cloud and
use both the dc's
and that would become an hybrid
environment all right so that was good
often
uh learning let's summarize the types of
cloud
based on deployment models and as we
know now
about the public cloud public cloud is
an cloud infrastructure
that's made available to the general
public over the internet
and it is owned by the cloud provider
some of the major players
as cloud providers are aws microsoft
azure
ibm's blue cloud and sun cloud and
private cloud
now this cloud infrastructure is
exclusively
operated by a single organization it can
be managed
by organizations or third party and may
exist on premises or off-premises
doesn't matter but the point here is
this is exclusively operated
for a single organization and some
companies that provide
private cloud are aws and vmware and
hybrid cloud gives the best of
both public and the private cloud for
example the federal agencies
they opt for private clouds for storing
and developing personal data
and they use public cloud to share the
non-sensitive data
with the general public or with other
government departments
now let's talk about different clouds
based on the service model if we need to
categorize them broadly we can
categorize them as
infrastructure as a service ias or
platform as a service
paas or software as a service sas
they sometimes are referred to as i as
pass and says
now at this moment you could be like
this guy thinking sam i thought you're
done
categorizing the cloud now you're going
to talk about
three more categories which one should i
pick well let me explain
if all that you want is just in vm and
you have all the expertise to install
the software on top of it and make it
work
then go for is if you only want a
platform
or an interface to program or an
interface to upload a program and make
it run
then pick pass or if all that you want
is a finished product hosted in the
cloud and be able to access it through
the internet then go for
sas here you get a username and password
for an application
and you can begin to customize the
application based on your needs
all right let's talk about is in a bit
more detail
is it gives basic computing infra
it's based on pay for what you use model
and some of the cloud providers who are
big
players are aws azure and google
and here the users generally will be id
admins
in pass the provider gives you a
platform or a runtime
environment for developing testing and
managing application
it's platform ready you buy the platform
you upload a code and you start working
on it
and it allows the software developers to
deploy applications
without running the underlying
infrastructure
and as you might have guessed by now the
interesting candidates who would use
pass
is software developers and in sas
everything is managed by
the vendor be it the hardware or the
software it's managed by the vendor and
we pay for the service and we pay for it
through a pay as you go subscription
model and as you might have guessed
the end users here would be end customer
itself all right let's put together
everything in the same page and compare
and contrast the different types of
service models
in this chart it explains the difference
between the four models
starting from on-premises to is and then
pass and says it is self-explanatory
that the resources
managed by us are huge in on-premises
and little less
in is and further less or reduced
in pass and nothing to manage when it
comes to sas
let me also explain the different types
of cloud services through
an example like this let's say that you
have a crush on
cake and you're planning to bake one
yourself
now let's look at the options you can
have you can make all the ingredients
yourself
be the floor butter and you know put
together and
bake the whole thing yourself using your
own oven pan
you know the needed water and the rest
you get idea right everything
is yours and that's on premises all that
you use
is owned by you and nothing is managed
by
the vendor the other options you can
have is buy the ingredients
and mix and bake the cake yourself now
this would be like is here the infra is
managed by the provider and we get to
use it
and customize it the way we want it here
the cloud service is then shared
responsibility the other options you
still
have on hand is simply pick a phone and
order a cake now this is a lot simpler
than the rest we discussed so far
you know it's simply picking the phone
and ordering the cake and pay for it
when it arrives simple and when it
reaches home
you will have to arrange the table
garnish the cake if that's needed
and then enjoy the cake it's the same
way with pass
just get the platform in which you would
run your code and upload your code
and start running your application here
you and the vendor still share
the responsibility you still have one
more option left that is
simply go out and dine this is a lot lot
simpler
that it requires no effort from us at
all you buy the fully finished and
garnished cake
and pay for it and walk out no
responsibility on making the cake it's
the same way with sass
we buy the finished product and pay for
the finished application
i really hope you enjoy this video i'll
meet you in the next video
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here